all right so we have our very first
reviews for the Marvels and what
definitely seems to be sort of a Disney
marketing plan and Marvel Studios
marketing plan here we have gotten the
first reviews for the Marvels from some
pretty big Outlets so it looks like
Marvel Studios and Disney decided to let
some of the major media Outlets see the
movie beforehand in hopes that they
would like the movie and talk about the
movie as much as they can obviously no
details about the movie could be given
but we do know what the first few
reactions are now and they are actually
quite good and this is one thing that
the Marvel's absolutely needs in order
to be relatively successful I did a
video a few weeks ago talking about how
I do believe the Marvels is destined to
fail because it has a lot going up
against it I do not want it to fail just
to clarify again I want the Marvels to
be successful I like Brie Larsson and I
like the cast I like Miss Marvel Monica
Rambo one of my favorite actors Park so
Jun is coming in this movie and of
course Nick Fury which could be viewed
as bad or good because right now some
people have sort of a bad taste of Nick
Fury right now in their mouths because
of that finale of secret Invasion but
although these movies are slightly
connected hopefully that doesn't affect
too many people from going out and
seeing the movie however sadly it is
definitely going to be a factor however
the first reviews are good and that is
what they needed so let's go over them
and let's talk about Disney and Marvel's
little marketing plan here and if you
love Marvel and you're new to the
channel be sure to subscribe so you
don't miss out on any of the latest news
and if you subscribe and leave a comment
you are automatically entered in our
giveaway for a chance to win a PS5 an
Xbox series X some Marvel Legends items
or some DC items the winner gets to pick
one item and we pick one winner at the
end of each month so like I said we have
reviews from some big Outlets like
Empire and IGN however you won't really
find anywhere on their websites what
they're saying about it yet and I'll
explain why these reviews are coming
from the Twitter account at cryptic
forwall this account count usually sees
trailers before they come out and they
have a 100% accuracy rate with
everything that they've said so far and
most of it is about trailers or movie
run times or release dates so this
account posted today stating some early
reviews for the Marvels and list a few
from Empire it says emotional hilarious
and action packed ignan says a sequel
that goes higher further faster and then
the Tweet says can't say which I'm
assuming cryptic HD quality is saying
that they can't say who the outlet is
for whatever reason I'm not sure but the
quote is an amazing film that takes us
on an emotional journey of growth and
teamwork now here's what I believe is
happening I think this account has seen
a new trailer for the Marvels ahead of
time and in that trailer like Marvel
Studios usually does like a lot of
movies do they put quotes in their
trailers so that is probably where this
account is getting these quotes from
however Marvel and Disney still are
doing something rather differently what
Marvel Studios usually does is they have
their really big Premiere the Red Carpet
World premiere and I'm fortunate to a
lot of the times get to go to these
premieres so I know how they typically
work at the same time as the premieres
on other locations they do screeners so
they allow other press members to see
the movie at the same time as the world
premiere then there's a reaction and a
social media embargo basically what that
means is Disney says you cannot say
anything until this day on this time you
can't review anything until this day at
this time typically the social media
embargo is immediately after you see the
movie so typically at a world premiere
the movie will start at around 700 p.m.
and the social media embargo is 9:00
p.m. that way when you get out of the
movie at 9:00 9:30 10: whatever it is
you can just automatically tweet about
it but Marvel Studios is doing something
different here they have allowed big
media press Outlets to see the movie
beforehand so they can release a trailer
before the world premiere to get people
hyped for this movie and they absolutely
needed to do this because this is a
movie that is going to seriously suffer
from the strikes right now none of the
cast have promoted the film at all they
haven't been able to because of the
guidelines of the strikes and this does
indeed Hurt movies when the cast members
and the main characters of the film
can't come out and say hey this movie we
love it we put so much heart and effort
into it it's going to be amazing you're
going to love it you're going to be on
the edge of your seat that actually does
really affect the box office and people
wanting to go see the movie and Marvel
is really being smart about this with
how they're going about this situation
to kind of maximize hype essentially
we'll dive into this more including what
the Marvel's is going to need to be a
successful movie in just a bit but first
big thank you to hellofresh for
sponsoring this video many of you
probably know by now that I personally
use hellofresh a lot because for me it
simply makes sense I have a pretty busy
schedule in my day-to-day life and
hellofresh just makes eating good meals
a lot easier for me with over 40
different recipes that I could choose
from each week hellofresh does all the
shopping and meal planning for you
ingredients arrive at your doorstep
pre-portioned and ready to cook along
with pictured step-by-step recipe cards
they literally make it as easy as it
possibly could be the meals are very
quick to make and they do include some
15-Minute Meals as well it takes the
hassle out of meal time but it also can
save you money hellofresh is cheaper
than grocery shopping and 25% less
expensive than takeout that means less
stress of worrying about what you're
going to eat and you save money so if
interested go to hellofresh.com
Cosmic and use code 50 Cosmic for 50%
off plus free shipping that's
hellofresh.com sl50 Cosmic and use code
50 Cosmic for 50% off plus free shipping
so what's funny about this is that
Disney and Marvel are almost essentially
leaking things themselves on purpose
ahead of time to create hype for the
movie which I totally get Marvel Studios
knows that there's a lot going against
this movie right now a lot of people
hate Brie Larson the strikes are
happening right now and it's also
connected to secret Invasion which did
not do very well plus the movie has to
make around 600 to$ 800 million to break
even not turn a profit but break even
and keep in mind Ant-Man of the WASP
Quantum Mania only did
476 million and they fully promoted Ed
that movie the cast fully promoted it
Marvel Studios everyone promoted it plus
not to mention it was our first time
really kind of seeing King the Conqueror
in action so there was a ton of hype
surrounding this movie it had a lot more
hype than the Marvel's does right now so
sadly there are a bunch of things that
are going against the Marvels right now
but Marvel Studios is trying to get
ahead of it so ultimately they're going
to start to release a lot of good quotes
about the movie soon they're going to
start to put these in trailers before
the actual World premiere and they've
let press see the movie already the
really big outlets at least and it
sounds like they actually have enjoyed
the movie and it kind of sounds like
essentially what we have been promised
it's funny it's action-packed and it's
better than the first one now based off
of the trailers that we've seen it does
look pretty action-packed and Miss
Marvel seems to bring a pretty good
comedic aspect to the film that I think
a lot of fans are going to enjoy Miss
Marvel the show has one of the highest
Disney plus ratings out there so
hopefully that will actually draw people
to go see the movie but they're going to
be using these good great amazing quotes
about the movie relatively soon to start
to increase that hype since there's not
really many more ways they can do that
the cast can't say anything they can't
really tweet about the movie post videos
anything like that they can't attend the
premiere for it so Marvel using these
quotes is them kind of trying to do some
damage control essentially and try to
increase the hype but keep in mind this
is kind of a warning now they probably
are going to use the best of the best
quotes for their trailers of course
because why would they use bad ones I
will say these Outlets typically don't
lie if they don't like a movie they
state it if they think it's medium they
state it and I can personally attest
that Marvel Studios does not pay people
for their quotes so not too long from
now when the premiere actually happens
we'll be getting all of the quotes not
just the good ones but the bad ones as
well and of course the ones that are mid
but overall I do hope this helps the
film I hope it helps create some hype
I'm really glad that IGN and Empire and
another Outlet are saying that the movie
is actually quite good some went as far
to say amazing and it does sound like
this is at least going to be better than
the first Captain Marvel film so I hope
it does increase excitement for the
movie let me know if you are excited for
this movie are you going to go see it
and if you are going to go see it are
you seeing it because you want to or
kind of just because it's the MCU and
you have to let us know all your
thoughts in the comments down below and
don't forget to like the video and
subscribe so you can stay up to date
with the Marvels and the MCU you can
find us on Instagram and Twitter and
always thank you all so much for
watching woof
woof